wer weiß schon heute
morgen sind jeden tag
er weiß schon heute morgen sind wir mal
wieder das neu beginnt
hinzu kommen
herzlich willkommen in unserem 16
hauptquartier im proberaum hier
ohne heizung ohne belüftung ohne fenster
kostet ich glaube 820 euro zahlen wie
münchen muss man froh sein überhaupt zu
einem proberaum hat der was taugt auch
hier kann ich diese geige anschließen
und dann kann ich das verzehr wahnsinn
das ist mein leben gerannt
wir schauen dass wir mindestens einmal
im monat proben und wir haben uns jetzt
vorgenommen dass wir das häufiger machen
der regel dauert das dann zwischen 1 und
5 stunden
wenn wir jetzt viele konzerte haben oder
wichtige projekte dann haben wir schon
jeden tag und dann gucken wir auf 67
stunden am stück arbeiten ja neuem album
und dann ist natürlich längere probezeit
jetzt irgendwie angedacht dafür haben ja
auch wir vielleicht schon gesehen hat
hier unsere volle spiegelwand aufgebaut
das ist tatsächlich so dass es mir sehr
geholfen hat wenn wir ein bisschen an
choreografie arbeiten was ein bisschen
übertrieben klingt wir einfach mal
schauen dass wir schön hin und her gehen
immer aber für mich ist es persönlich
mal ganz wichtig dass ich weiß wo dazu
besteht damit ich mich sicher fühle auf
der bühne weil ich gebe ihm sicherheit
auf der wenigen noch lieben deswegen
liegen leute zu reden lassen gesehen zu
vergeben
das macht